I hate intros the psychopath movie we
kick things off in the year 21 16 three
years after kogami had killed Mishima
and went missing and since then nobody
has heard from him octoman the others
capture a group of mercenaries and after
a memory scoop it's revealed that they
knew kogami akame gets permission from
civil to go to the war-torn Southeast
Asian Union to track him down as he
appears to be a part of a guerrilla
force fighting the government the seu is
also the first foreign power to try
implementing a proxy version of the
civil system she conveniently runs into
him on her second day there and goes
with him to her guerrilla hideout he
explains that they're fighting against a
military dictatorship the hideout is
attacked by mercenaries led by rude
agonda forcing aki-nee to fooi back to
the city while kogami gets captured once
back aki-nee with the help of she own
uncovered the fact that the military had
tampered with the Sibyl system and are
all actually Layton criminals Kagame is
brought to the city by route agonda so
that they can kill him and aki-nee while
placing the blame on kogami this is
prevented by the Sibyl system who
intervenes and starts executing all the
soldiers division-one shows up in a
helicopter to help in the struggle where
all the soldiers die except for rue de
ganda so Kagame goes after him Kagame
teams up with his old friend he knows it
to take down route agonda in an epic
fight that ends in brute agonda being
killed he knows that then let's go gommi
go free instead of taking him into
custody so he once again disappears
akame confronts chairman Han the leader
of the SCA you who is actually an
Android a part of the Sibyl system the
Sibyl system orchestrated all of these
events including the foreign terrorists
sneaking into Japan all so they could
expand their influence over the country
akame says that they should have a fair
election and civil agrees to this so
they have the Android chairman Han
announced he is stepping down in the
last scene after the credits we get a
look at Kagame who's living a rather
peaceful life and learned that the
Chairman is still winning the elections
next up is the sinners of the system
trilogy case one where he'd come in six
months after the first movie had taken
place there is a chase where Mika anggee
knows that apprehend a female criminal
on the run
named yo Socky Izumi who can't really
talk she also appears to be suffering
from some sort of drug addiction but
they don't know what drug they are
ordered to return he's Umi to the
isolation facility called sanctuary
where she used to be a therapist then
became a prisoner after her score rose
they also get permission to do a
security check once they get out there
but a kanay wants to work the case from
Tokyo
this leaves Mika Yayoi anggee Nosa as
her escort back when they arrive they
get a nice Welcome Party from the
supervisor Suzy Cho kyoka along with
some of the staff I go kuda Sawa Rosie
on matsuki and the rat bro koji Noto as
Mika tries to investigate the conditions
of the facility and why is Umi tried to
escape she finds nobody will give her
answers over to Aki nee who is following
up a lead named Takata whose name was
muttered by Azumi during her arrest they
go to his place and speculate that he
might have been kidnapped
Yayoi is then arrested for helping Azumi
escape for the second time which she
denies spot in actuality she was ordered
to let her go by Mika Ruthie's umi
missing again they send out leighton
criminals to detain her since they know
the area in response to this mika Anki
knows us set out to find her before the
others they managed to get ahead of the
search parties and find her at a
cemetery with a little boy named kukuda
Takuya the name she muttered during her
arrest his mother was pregnant when she
was taken to the facility but was killed
after finding out too much about
sanctuary
so he's Umi is raising him in her stead
the boy has a memory cube but the files
on it seemed to be locked the search
parties arrive soon after and they
wouldn't take Azumi into their custody
instead so this forces everybody to flee
when the memory cube gets unlocked
there's a video of Izumi explaining
what's going on at sanctuary the
supervisor kyoka is using drugs and
hypnosis to brainwash the prisoners
there and kills anybody who finds out
the truth Azumi was taking the child's
drugs so he didn't have to which is why
she can't really talk anymore they
decide to split up with Mika going into
the mines where the criminals are forced
to work walkie knows it goes and sets
Yayoi free document binds Takeda I
thought I'd the boy's father who died
under mysterious circumstances
Shion also found a new lead in kata suma
Akita and this doesn't sit too well with
Aki nee sensing
something is off Akane decides to go
join Mika and the others at sanctuary
back over to me go who found radioactive
canisters in the mines but is found in
captured by supervisor kiyoka Ginoza and
Yayoi are attacked by Rosie on matsuki
in his badass mech but Sookie has a
bronze mechanics and kind of runs it
down so he knows it takes out the mech
without any real trouble meanwhile mica
is paraded around in front of all of the
prisoners and they plan on killing her
before they can though she exposes kyoka
to all of the prisoners with the
recording showing that she is just using
them to collect the canisters until they
die and doesn't care about them at all
this turns all of the prisoners against
her and as this is happening Yayoi forms
a connection to Sybil allowing me to use
her Dominator Lucas cores a 421 just
with one point over dying a legend but
Mika doesn't care and goes on to execute
her jump on back over to get knows it
for the cliche 1v1 fistfight against the
final boss matsuki he knows that ends up
winning the fight and instead of being
executed by the dominator matsuki lets
go of the ledge he was clinging to
falling to his death the prisoners go
out of control attacking the staff and
anybody nearby so the gang is forced to
run a kanay and her team arrived just in
the nick of time to evacuate everybody
out to safety when they return Mika
meets with goddess Ouma the mastermind
behind everything which turns out to be
surprise surprise the Sibyl system Sybil
had set everything in motion to keep the
radioactive waste hidden away following
the events sanctuary is shut down and
the prisoners are sent to rehabilitation
facilities including a zoomy who is
returning to normal with the drugs
wearing off she plans to raise Takeo
once she is fully recovered and released
from the facility moving on to the
second movie of the trilogy case - we
come in on October 21 16 introducing
Hana Shido Frederika a new transfer as
the inspectors assistant Sugo Taipei who
is now an enforcer in Division one
because of the death of Sakuya talks
with Frederika we learned he used to be
the ace of the fifteenth joint military
task force as a pilot known as first
guardian Frederika tells him that the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs is creating
new units and wants him to join to have
back for years where we are introduced
to some new faces while Sugo was in the
military
we have Otomo Itsuki who is one of Sue
goes close friends and Otomo's why preen
Sugo and Otomo are a test with the
secret mission launching an attack in
the SGA you podemos fighting on the
ground while Sugo provides air support
with his drone the operation ends up
failing and Sugo is ordered to drop his
relief supplies to autumn oh and his men
before leaving them behind rain who was
pregnant at the time miscarried shortly
after and quit the military
animos labelled missing in action and we
jump ahead three months where the
Ministry of Defense building is attacked
by a drone Inspector ienaga from season
2 and enforcer ma sucah from season 1
are put on the case they show Sugo
footage of autumn oh who is caught on
camera and is a suspect in the attack
Kagame Ginoza and Kagame are also
helping with the investigation elsewhere
the other three go to talk to Reem but
that's a dead end because she doesn't
know anything we get a little side story
when Moscow goes to visit his ex-wife
who can't move or talk he knows it finds
out about this and isn't happy with him
visiting his mom for whatever reason we
get a second drone attack where more
people are killed including Paquita
Kyokai who was present during the foot
stamp operation where autumn Oh went
missing Sugo finds us suspicious so he
goes to talk with his boss lieutenant
general minatoya after losing his cool
trying to find the truth he is taken
into custody by the guards takasu
yoshida a colonel that took part in foot
stamp also tells Misaka and i Yanagi
that he doesn't want them sniffing
around military secrets meanwhile Sugo
is locked into a chair and it's revealed
that he is suspected by mina toya of
cracking into the military database
after foot stand
he plans to fake a training accident and
drill into suga's ID but the machine is
turned off just in time by Misaka and
aya Nagi they had just been given more
authority by Sibyl so their
investigation can't be hindered by the
brass afterward they continue the
investigation where Sugo gets the idea
to check the brandy that autumn Oh had
mentioned during the mission when they
look into it they find a chip inside of
it the chip reveals that autumn OCAD be
hiding at a submarine dock so they go to
check it out they finally find autumn oh
where he makes quick work of moussaka
and aya Nagi now it's a 1v1 between him
and Sugo which suka
revealing that it's actually a robot
they're fighting the roba is replicating
aughtta most personality based off of a
life log that he had been keeping the
robot tells Sugo that a demo is dead and
operation foot stamp was really just
about having su go deliver what he
thought was relief supplies to autumn
'as men in actuality what Sugo had
dropped was a chemical weapon which
ended up killing autumn oh and his squad
who were disposable and expected to die
during the mission the chemicals also
went on to wipe out all of the forces
that they were fighting with which was
the overall goal we then get a look at
Marine who was actually the one who
programmed the robot to carry out these
acts of terrorism for revenge well
everybody was dealing with the robots
she goes on to attempt assassinations on
the higher-ups responsible for the
mission she successfully kills Mina Toya
but then is shot by Yoshi losing her
life Yoshida is later judged by Massa
cos Dominator and killed because of his
actions in operation foot stamp after a
couple of years sue go drops to Layton
criminal status and joins the bureau as
an enforcer this was just a few months
after Masako was killed by makishima so
they never got to see each other again
also keep in mind that sugah was the one
that killed aya Nagi in season 2 not
knowing it was her because his sniper
judged her score through a wall and he
thought it was the perp and finally in
the last scene we jump back to the
present where he turns down Frederika
job offer now let's wrap up the trilogy
with system case 3 the last movie takes
place a year and four months after we
saw Kagame in the closing scenes of the
movie he is now in Tibet where he
encounters a man named Garcia after a
bar brawl who offers him a job but
Kagame refuses this by being turned down
Garcia still has one of his guys named
Selim give Kagame a ride to the capital
regime choose off a little background on
the region reveals that it's military
has fallen and it's full of ethnic
conflicts and guerrilla warfare well on
their trip they end up rescuing a bus of
refugees from guerilla fighters Kagame
then takes the bus the rest of the way
to the capital parting ways with Selene
a girl named tan Jean who was a
passenger on the bus and saw his skills
approaches him asking him to be her
teacher
her family was killed by guerilla
fighters and she wants to learn how to
fight so that she can avenge them Kagame
agrees to this as long as she uses it
for defense and not for vengeance they
go on to meet with her uncle who gives
them a place to stay and we get
flashbacks of the massacre where her
parents were killed Kagame goes on to
train her and teaches her how to read
Japanese
one day Hana Shido Frederika who offered
sugah a job in case two finds Kagame
wall on a secret mission while they are
talking the uncle comes in and requests
kogami 'he's help after a supply team
was attacked
Frederika offers her help as well and
they all proceed to the fight after
killing makishima Kagame tries his best
not to kill anybody so while fighting he
shoots a kid in the leg when he turns
away to let the kid go the kid pulls a
pistol and hits Kagame injuring him but
Frederika saves his life with her sniper
garcia and his men hired by the
government show up to help deter the
attack the peace monitoring group led by
Garcia is making great progress and
lowering the violence in the region
Frederika continues to stay with them
for a bit and she tells kogami how
everybody in Division 1 is doing since
she had worked with them for a short
time there is a bombing that kills the
purple dragon clan leader who refused to
cooperate with Garcia and his men in
peace talks the new leader however seems
to be more open with peace negotiations
Garcia gets all of the factions together
to negotiate a ceasefire but they can't
come to an agreement
meanwhile tension goes to a market where
she spots the man who killed her parents
she follows him and sees him meet with
Garcia where we learned that they were
the ones responsible for assassinating
the purple dragon leader then Jeanne
contemplates killing him with kogami's
revolver that she took when he wasn't
looking but can't bring herself to do it
that's ok though because Garcia betrays
him and kills the man right after this
happens Tanjung accidentally makes a
noise and garcia blindly throws a knife
towards the sound one garcia goes to
investigate he finds kogami x' revolver
on the ground we then see that Tenjin
was hit by the knife and is badly
injured
kogami manages to find her and she tells
him about garcia meanwhile garcia is
convinced that kogami was the witness so
he tells his men that kogami was
responsible for the purple dragon
leaders assassination salim doesn't
believe this so he goes to help Kagame
get out of this pinch
everybody decides that it would be best
to leave Garcia alive until the peace
negotiations are settled so they are
laying low the ceasefire is finally made
and Garcia's men will be moving on so
they plan to hit them while they are in
motion Garcia and his men are traveling
by train and they managed to separate
him from most of his men by detaching
the back half of the train Suleiman
Frederika deal with most of the
leftovers until we get the iconic final
boss 1v1 it's a pretty decent fight
until kogami stabs him with his own
knife killing him and then goes on to
retrieve his revolver Selim takes over
Garcia's position and Kagame takes the
fall for the assassination of both
Garcia and the purple dragon leader to
make sure the ceasefire stays on track
meanwhile ten gene who is rushed to a
hospital survived and is now recovering
in the last scene Kagame talks with
Frederika and we learned that he is
planning on returning to japan with her
most likely because he agreed to the job
offer that she was originally offering
Sugo I'm gonna be doing the future
seasons an that'll be in the bottom left
whenever I'm finish with it or you can
check out all the Psychopaths recaps in
this playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outros